.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Willst du auch noch mal?
Nur die auf den Kopf.
Samuel und Virginie sind Zwillinge.
Er hat das Downsyndrom. Sie nicht.
Wir beide mögen Menschen gerne
und wir mögen es, wenn etwas läuft.
Wir beide mögen die Natur.
Worin seid ihr unterschiedlich?
Bei der Ordnung und beim Einhalten
von Regeln ist er sehr streng.
Willst du nicht auch?
- Ich darf nicht.
Er ist der Korrekte von uns zwei.
- Das ist verboten.
Samuel
wohnt bei Virginie und ihrer Familie.
In drei Monaten
erwartet sie ihr zweites Kind.
Du solltest deiner
schwangeren Schwester kurz helfen.
Wie organisieren sich
die ungleichen Zwillinge im Alltag?
Wie gelingt Virginie der Spagat
zwischen Mutter und Schwester sein?
Können die Bedürfnisse aller
auch in Zukunft gestillt werden?
Das sind grosse Fragen.
Wie kann ich
alles meistern und machen?
Je mehr wir ihn miteinbeziehen ...
... und er mithelfen, Verantwortung
und Aufgaben übernehmen darf,
desto besser.
Schau, da.
Ich begleite die beiden von jetzt Ð
drei Monate vor der Geburt -
bis drei Monate danach.
Zeig mal, wie man schiefert.
- Ich weiss nicht.
Nein, einfach machen.
Es hat genug Steine.
Ich weiss nicht.
Ich habe einen Stein.
Das ist das Zuhause von Virginie,
ihrem Mann und dem kleinen Marvin.
Seit zwei Jahren auch von Samuel.
In unregelmässigen Abständen
wohnt er zudem bei den Eltern.
Nicht alles, Sämi.
Virginie arbeitet drei Tage pro Woche
als Lehrerin.
Daneben dem einjährigen Marvin
gerecht zu werden,
Samuel und auch noch sich selbst Ð
das stelle ich mir schwierig vor.
Ich glaube,
es ist eine Herzenseinstellung.
Für mich ist es das Normalste
der Welt, dass er dazugehört.
Ich möchte ihn nicht ausschliessen,
wenn ich irgendwo hingehe.
Natürlich gibt es gewisse Momente.
Aber es ist eine Grundhaltung,
dass er in mein Leben,
in meinen Alltag integriert ist.
Papa.
- (Mann) Ja.
Hm. Bäbä-Mäm.
Hoi.
Unterstützt wird die 32-Jährige
von ihrem Mann Faik.
Er arbeitet 100 %
als Landschaftsgärtner.
Willst du da rein?
Soll ich mich nach hinten setzen?
Willst du auch? Vielleicht.
- Marvin, willst du auch essen?
Bis vor zwei Jahren
lebte Samuel in verschiedenen
betreuten Institutionen.
Er sei unglücklich
und aggressiv gewesen,
bekam Medikamente zur Beruhigung.
Am Wochenende war er jeweils bei
Virginie und Faik oder den Eltern.
Es war immer ein riesiges Drama
am Sonntagabend ...
... wenn wir Samuel zurückbrachten.
Manchmal wollte er
nicht aus dem Auto aussteigen.
Dann warteten wir stundenlang
draussen und er im Auto -
man schaute, wer stärker ist
und wer noch mehr Ausdauer hat.
Wenn wir dann nach Hause fuhren,
mussten wir eingestehen,
dass es uns das Herz bricht.
Das mitanzusehen
und so stark bleiben zu können ...
Es hatte ja einen Grund,
warum er nicht aussteigen wollte.
Du warst der, der sagte:
"Komm, wir holen ihn."
Ich hätte gesagt: "Noch nicht."
"Wir brauchen
noch etwas Familienzeit."
Für mich gehört das dazu.
In meiner Familie
kümmert man sich um die Familie.
Faik ist ursprünglich aus der Türkei.
Seit vier Jahren
ist er mit Virginie zusammen.
Machst du das gerne?
- Megagerne, ja.
Ich arbeite sehr korrekt.
Ich arbeite megagerne.
Ich und Faik arbeiten zusammen.
Ja.
Faik sagt mir,
von Anfang sei klar gewesen:
Virginie gibt es nur im Doppelpack.
Wenn man damit umgehen will ...
... muss man manchmal über seinen
Schatten springen und das lernen.
Das war etwas sehr Wertvolles
für mich.
Und ...
Eben ...
Ich lerne noch heute.
Auch du, Sämi.
Und das ist das Schöne daran.
Inzwischen ist Faik
in diese spezielle Patchworkfamilie
reingewachsen.
Bei Virginie war es anders.
Ihr Zwillingsbruder
war seit jeher an ihrer Seite.
Weisst du, warum du
im Brutkasten warst?- Nein.
Es ging dir nicht so gut.
Nicht gut.
- Darum mussten wir raus.
Rauskommen mit dem Kopf.
- Nein, Kaiserschnitt.
Wir hatten einen Kaiserschnitt.
Da ist Papa, wie er mich streichelt.
Da ist Virginie.
Wir sind Zwillinge.
- Schon krass, oder? Zwei Babys.
Wer kam zuerst auf die Welt?
Zuerst ich und dann Virginie.
- Genau.
Zuerst ich. Ich war sofort da.
Ich habe immer geboxt.
Geboxt habe ich.
Ich wollte raus.
Mami sagt immer,
du warst immer ein Wilder.
Sie hat auch eins im Bauch.
- Richtig.
Er war immer der Extrovertierte
und ich die Introvertierte.
Als Kinder und als Jugendliche.
Wie war es für dich,
dass er gerne im Mittelpunkt stand?
Ich fand das nicht so toll, dass er
immer die Aufmerksamkeit wollte.
Ich versteckte mich oft hinter Mami.
Ich war sehr ruhig und scheu.
Erst in der Jugend
ging Virginie ihren eigenen Weg.
Von der Kanti
bis zur Ausbildung selber ...
Dort wohnte ich
dann auch in einer WG.
Ich wohnte nicht mehr zu Hause.
Ich musste mich wie abgrenzen,
um auch mal wie ...
... rauszufinden ...
... was ich überhaupt will.
Welche Rolle möchte ich einnehmen?
Ich werde nie seine Mutter sein.
Das möchte
weder ich noch meine Eltern.
Die Schwester, ja.
Aber in welchem Rahmen?
* Energetische Musik *
Ich frage mich:
Wie viel Platz bleibt Virginie heute?
Klar ist:
Samuel nimmt sich seinen Raum.
So auch jetzt:
Er übt für seine Tanzgruppe.
Du kannst winken.
Ja, ich muss jeden Tag üben.
Üben?
- Ja.
Wofür?
- Wir haben bald Aufführung.
Ah, okay.
- Mhm.
Kann ich auch kommen?
- Ja.
Ui-ui-ui.- Was hast du da?
- Marvin entdeckt die Welt.
Samuel ist Polizeifan -
für ihn ist Ordnung wichtig.
Du musst gehorchen. Und zuhören.
Und ... Ja.
- (Marvin) Nein.
Samuel?
Zunehmend muss Virginie
zwischen den beiden vermitteln.
Das ist jetzt so eine Situation.
Er ist etwas ungeduldig.
Samuel hat seine eigene Strategie,
um Konflikte zu verarbeiten.
"Entschuldigung", habe ich gesagt.
Jetzt ist er auf der Toilette.
Er hat irgendeinen Konflikt
mit sich. In sich drin.
Es war irgendetwas.
Dann geht er auf die Toilette ...
... und spricht mit sich selber,
um das zu verarbeiten.
Wenn mit dir gestritten wird.
Da muss ich jeweils spionieren
und zuhören.
Dann geht ja nichts anderes,
als sich reinzumischen.
Nicht einfach entschuldigen.
Wir nicht.
Samuel, ist alles gut?
- Ja, gut. Ja.
Ja.
- Sicher? Hast du dich gestritten?
Nein. Nur kommentiert.
- Nicht?
Was musst du kommentieren?
Wegen Marvin.
- Wegen Marvin.
Hat er dich geärgert?
Ja.
Wirklich?
- Nicht schlimm.
* Er ruft Unverständliches. *
Ein wichtiger Teil von Samuels Leben
sind - neben der Schwester -
die Eltern.
Er wohnt teilweise bei ihnen.
Bei der Geburt ihrer Kinder
waren Rose-Marie und Emmanuel Bickit
überrascht:
diskordante Downsyndrom-Zwillinge -
ein äusserst seltenes Phänomen.
In der Schweiz gibt es
schätzungsweise eine Handvoll.
Das war natürlich
ein Schock für mich.
Ich hatte
eine wunderbare Schwangerschaft.
Ich arbeitete bis zum Ende.
Und ...
Ich dachte: "Zwillinge -
da ist alles in Ordnung."
Mein Mann sagte:
"Du musst nicht traurig sein."
"Wer weiss ..."
Sag du es: "Wer weiss ..."
- "Wer weiss, was auf uns zukommt."
Ich nahm es an, wie es ist.
Samuel stand wegen
seiner gesundheitlichen Probleme
von Anfang an im Mittelpunkt.
Der Kinderarzt gab ihnen einen Rat.
"Rose-Marie, du musst darauf achten,
dass Virginie nicht zu kurz kommt."
Dass ich nicht immer nur
auf Samuel fokussiert sein solle.
Virginie sei auch noch da.
Obwohl das spontan immer wieder kam.
"Samuel ... Was macht er jetzt?
Virginie, schau schnell."
Das hat ihr auch die Rolle
des Leitpfades gegeben.
Sie ist Samuels Leaderin.
Sie ist verantwortlich.
Das kam instinktiv und spontan.
Um beiden gerecht zu werden,
kämpften sie bei den Behörden dafür,
dass auch Kinder mit Beeinträchtigung
in eine Regelklasse können.
Mit Erfolg: Samuel durfte
in einen regulären Kindergarten.
Im Nachhinein ...
Ich weiss nicht ...
Samuel hatte so viele Freunde.
Ich, ja.
- Im Kindergarten und nachher.
Aber v.a. vom Kindergarten.
Aber die sind jetzt alle verheiratet
und haben Kinder.
Die wollen ... Wir haben
keinen Kontakt mehr mit ihnen.
Und er will keinen Kontakt
zu Behinderten.
(Virginie) Unser Jahrgang, alle, die
32 sind und Downsyndrom haben ...
Sie alle sagen: "Ich möchte
keinen behinderten Freund."
Weil ihnen vermittelt wurde,
sie seien anormal.
Was nicht falsch ist.
Aber ...
Die Eltern wünschen sich,
dass Samuel bei Virginie lebt,
wenn sie einmal nicht mehr da sind.
Unterstützung wird er immer brauchen.
Obwohl er seinen Arbeitsweg
allein bewältigen kann.
Ich muss auf Gleis 6
und dann nach Winterthur.
Vier Tage pro Woche
arbeitet er in Münsterlingen
in einer Stiftung im Gartenbereich.
* Er spricht mit sich selbst. *
Guten Morgen.
- Guten Morgen, Samuel.
Du kannst die Feile nehmen.
Heute stellt er Wildbienenhotels her.
Angeleitet von seinem Betreuer
Börge Pietschmann.
Das Röhrchen wird dann
von Wildbienen besetzt.- Mhm.
Wie siehst du die Wohnsituation?
Also,
dass er bei der Schwester wohnt?
Ich finde es grundsätzlich gut,
dass er bei der Schwester wohnt.
Und auch,
dass er gerne zur Mami geht.
Ich finde einfach, dass Samuel
ein erwachsener Mann ist.
Er sollte ...
... ein eigenes Zuhause
in einer Wohngruppe haben.
Wo schon jemand da ist
und ihn im Wohnen begleitet ...
... aber wo er etwas mehr Abstand
von der Familie hat.
Nicht zu lange
bei einem Röhrchen bleiben.
Schauen, Feile nehmen ...
Blas mal rein.
Gut, oder? Schon fertig.
- Ja.
Das nächste.
Ich sehe da eine Sackgasse.
Auch beim Thema Partnerwahl.
Und zum Thema, wie es ist, wenn er
mal eine Freundin mitbringt.
Samuel möchte - wie wir auch -
die Freundin in ein völlig
neutrales Umfeld bringen.
Ohne dass etwas ist.
Sie sollen
auch Erfahrungen machen dürfen.
Man muss die Beeinträchtigung
immer im Kontext sehen.
Aber man muss auch ...
... trotzdem so viel ausprobieren,
wie möglich.
Ja. Selbstständig sein können.
So weit wie möglich.
Nicht so wenig wie möglich.
In dieser Stiftung findet auch ein
Teil von Samuels Sozialleben statt.
Dann mache ich noch die Session.
Die muss ich machen.
Entschuldigung,
dass ich meinen Senf dazugebe.
Ich bin Hansruedi Klee. Ich ...
- Mein Name ist Samuel Bickit.
Ich arbeite gerne
mit Samuel zusammen.
Wir machen Entsorgung.
- Mein Kollege bei der Entsorgung.
Ich sitze manchmal
zusammen mit ihm am Mittagstisch.
Wir haben wirklich ...
- Chilliges Leben, Polizei, Musik.
Genau,
wir haben auch schon Musik gemacht.
Oder ein Bier trinken.
- Genau.
Oder?
Er wohnt auch am Untersee.
* Lachen *
Das hast du gut gesagt.
Ich treffe die Zwillinge
einen Monat später wieder.
Übers Kreuz.
- So?- Ja.
Bis zur Geburt des zweiten Kindes
dauert es noch sechs Wochen.
Ich habe mich konzentriert.
- Hey, cool.
Das ist meine Waffe.
- Eine riesige Waffe.
Er hat für sich natürlich
den grössten Grittibänz gemacht.
Das muss immer sein.
Mit einer riesigen Waffe.
Mir ist gerade aufgefallen,
dass er ... Ist das der Kopf?- Ja.
Der kommt hier oben hin.
Er hatte das Gefühl,
er käme zu kurz.
Kannst du mir erklären,
wer hier wer ist?
Das ist wir. Das ist die Polizei.
"Das bin ich."
- Das bin ich und die Polizei.
Oh, das klebt fest.
Bei deinem Sohn Marvin weisst du,
dass er grösser
und selbstständiger wird.
Das geht in eine Richtung.
Aber bei Samuel ...
Er bleibt ja immer etwas ...
... abhängig. Ja.
- ... abhängig von dir.
Wie ist das für dich?
Das ist einfach so. Das ...
Ja, das ist so.
Wir sind Lebewesen,
die einander brauchen.
Wir sind nicht ...
Wir brauchen einander sowieso.
Fürs Soziale
und damit wir glücklich sind.
Die einen
brauchen etwas mehr Unterstützung
und die anderen weniger.
Die einen brauchen es
vom Charakter her mehr, aber ja ...
Zu Virginies Entlastung nimmt Faik
Samuel manchmal zum Arbeiten mit.
Heute zum Christbaumverkauf.
- Hast du gesehen? Willst du auch?
Schau, da hat es Schokolade.
Du kannst das so machen.
- Mhm.
So.
Einen Knopf und dann hinhängen.
- Ja.
Machst du das ein bisschen?
Wenn du Hilfe brauchst,
kannst du mich rufen.- Ja.
Irgendwann
wurde ich einfach sein Bruder.
Jetzt bin ich sogar sein Vater.
Ja, ja.- Wie ist das,
wenn er dich Papi nennt?
Zu Hause ist das noch cool,
aber wenn er das draussen sagt ...
Es ist schon lustig, aber ...
Das erschreckt mich auch etwas.
Anfangs war das im Spass,
aber dann ...
... denkt man darüber nach.
Die Verantwortung liegt bei mir.
Auch eine väterliche.
Aber nicht nur das.
Es ist auch schön ...
Wenn er "Vater" sagt ...
... akzeptiert er mich auch mehr.
Warte, warte, warte.
Ich muss aufmachen.
Ich gehe schnell dorthin.
Jetzt.
Tust du ihn an die Leine, bitte?
Ich mag Hunde nicht so.
(Mann) Wie?
- Mit der Leine anbinden.
Leine.
- Kannst du ruhig sein?
Hey.
So spricht man nicht
mit fremden Leuten.
Was ist los, Sämi?
- Er macht komischer Mann.
Halt du doch die Klappe.
Dumme Leute.
Sämi. Pst.
- Arschlochleute.
Was ist los?
- Nichts.- Was ist los?
Ich sagte, er müsse anbinden.
- Was anbinden?
Das darfst du nicht sagen.
- Wieso nicht?
Das darfst du nicht.
- Wieso?
Bist du ein Polizist?
- Nein.
Also, er darf seinen Hund
ohne Leine führen.
Ja.
Also gut. Das lassen wir so stehen.
- Ja.
Fertig.
- Ja. Entschuldigung.
Du musst dich nicht entschuldigen.
- Ich habe nichts gemacht.
Es ist gut. Fertig.
Fertig. Das ist jetzt fertig.
- Ja. Ja.
Fertig.
Samuel?- Ich gehe nicht mehr.
Das ist fertig. Ich gehe nicht mehr.
Gut. Sämi, fertig.
- Ja.
Ich will nichts mehr hören.
Sonst gehen wir nach Hause.- Ja.
Faik gelingt es, ihn zu beruhigen.
Den Rest klärt Samuel wie üblich
mit seinen imaginären Freunden.
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
Ein komischer Hund.
Das ist schwierig.
Und die Leute verstehen nicht.
Das Problem ist überall.
Das macht mich nicht wütend.
Das geht einfach nicht.
Das habe ich auch gesagt.
Aber er hat es nicht verstanden.
Nein, er soll aufhören, blöd zu tun.
Ja. Aber beim nächsten Mal weggehen.
Ja, das habe ich gemacht.
Gut. Danke vielmals.
Danke für alles. Danke. Ade.
* Sanfte Musik *
Noch drei Wochen bis zur Geburt.
Früh am Morgen ist schon einiges los
bei Virginie und ihrer Familie.
Ich gebe dir ein Büchlein.
Was macht ihr?
Ich muss staubsaugen, weil viele
meiner Haare auf dem Boden sind.
Er wollte sich noch schön machen
und schnitt sich kurzerhand
die Haare.
Selber.
Hier vorne ...
- Ja.
Aber weil er Locken hat,
ist es nicht so schlimm.- Genau.
Wobei braucht Samuel Hilfe?
Er kann vieles allein.
Aber er braucht etwas Kontrolle.
- Ja, Kontrolle muss sein.
Wie unabhängig soll er sein
oder werden?
Kann er das überhaupt?
- Das habe ich mir gerade überlegt.
Was definiert das?
Ist er nicht jetzt schon sehr frei
und unabhängig?
Ich finde,
solange er sich selber ...
Solange er
zufrieden ist mit seinem Leben,
fehlt ihm ja nichts.
Ah.
Oh my God.
Ich weiss, dass
sein sehnlichster Wunsch ist ...
* Marvin weint. *
So. Besser?
- Mhm.
Sein sehnlichster Wunsch ist,
eine Partnerin zu finden.
Das wünsche ich ihm auch.
Aber das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Wie müsste deine Freundin sein?
- Eine grosse Frau.
Eine Blonde-Haar-Frau.
- Eine Blonde?- Ja.
Soll sie auch Downsyndrom haben?
Keine Behinderung. Nein.
Das ist eben der Punkt.
Wo lernt er jemanden kennen?
Wen soll er kennenlernen?
- Nein.
Mhm.
Wunderbar.
- Wunderbar?
Hier in der Tanzgruppe
für Menschen mit Beeinträchtigung
wäre eigentlich der ideale Ort,
um eine Partnerin kennenzulernen.
Aber eben - alles Frauen
nicht nach Samuels Gusto.
Sie proben für ihren Auftritt
in wenigen Wochen.
* Heitere Musik *
Magst du nicht mehr?
Ist es nicht gut?
Was ist los?
- Ich weiss auch nicht.
Hm?
Ist etwas nicht gut?
- Nein.
Möchtest du sagen, was?
- Nein, ist gut.
Hm?
Ich weiss nicht,
was in Samuel vorgeht.
Virginie sagte mir einmal,
selbst als Zwillingsschwester
kenne sie das.
Das Beste dann:
die Situation stehen lassen.
Oft sei es pure Überforderung
mit seinen Emotionen.
Die Stimmung
wechsle meist von allein wieder.
* Heitere Popmusik *
So.
Wir warten noch auf Sämi und Papa.
Das ist der ruhigste Moment
des ganzen Tages.
Die Ruhe ist äusserst willkommen.
Virginie steht kurz vor der Geburt.
Ich muss mich an der Nase nehmen
und immer wieder Pause machen.
Mich etwas hinlegen -
dann geht es mir gut.
Und es sind Ferien.
Ich muss nicht mehr arbeiten.
Dann geht es auch gut.
* Heitere Musik *
Hoi.
- Hallo.
- Hoi.
* Marvin weint. *
Was ist denn los? Oh.
Er sagt: "Es ist viel zu spät."
* Ruhiges Kinderlied *
Mach etwas leiser.
Ein bisschen leiser.
Samuel, du musst etwas leiser.
Wegen der Nachbarn.
Entschuldigung.
* Er macht die Musik lauter. *
Samuel.
Es gibt schon Momente,
in denen ich ungeduldig bin.
Aber innerlich weiss ich ...
... ich muss mich
schnell beherrschen.
Es bringt nichts,
wenn ich ungeduldig werde.
Das ist dann wie ein Gegenläufer.
Er spürt die Unruhe dann auch.
Darum ...
- In sich selber.
... habe ich gelernt,
besser schnell rauszugehen.
Oder ich sage Faik: "Ich mag nicht."
"Übernimm du!"
Eines darf am Abend nicht fehlen:
Die Gute-Nacht-Milch.
Nein.
Doch.
- Doch.
Jetzt gehst du ins Bett.
Es ist schon 21.15 Uhr.
Einen Gruss.
- Mhm.
Gute Nacht. Bye-bye.
Wie beeinflusst die Entscheidung,
dass Samuel hier ist,
euer Familienleben?
Welches Familienleben? Nein.
Spontan fällt mir ein ... Vielleicht
haben wir weniger Privatsphäre.
Oder Zeit für uns.
Oft geht es bei den beiden um Samuel.
Besonders in der letzten Zeit.
Er hat eine Frau kennengelernt.
Sie ist 60 Jahre alt.
Ohne Beeinträchtigung.
Das ist kein ...
... einfaches Thema. Für niemanden.
Was machen wir und wie? All das.
Er hat seine Bedürfnisse,
die haben wir alle.
Das ist nicht so einfach.
Im ersten Moment
ist es schon irgendwie komisch.
Aber vielleicht
ist es wirklich Liebe.
Dem wollen wir
ja nicht im Weg stehen.
Ich hatte eher das Gefühl,
es schade Samuel.
Darum war ich eher dagegen.
Weil er sich
auch uns gegenüber verschloss.
Er wollte
nichts mehr mit uns zu tun haben.
Über allem steht ja die Frage:
Wie viel Fürsorge braucht er ...
... und wie viel Freiraum?
Und wo geht es ihm dabei am besten?
- Mhm.
Ich finde das megaschwierig.
Das ist schwierig.
Eine Partnerschaft ist ja schon ...
Dass ich das für mich selber
entscheide, ist schon schwierig.
Diese Frage noch
für jemand anderes zu übernehmen ...
Ich möchte ihm ja die Freiheit
schenken, das selber zu entscheiden.
Aber:
Kann er das selber entscheiden?
Wie viel versteht er?
Mit all den Konsequenzen ...
Sexualität, Aufklärung ...
* Sie stammelt. *
Keine Ahnung.- Oder hat er
das Recht, da reinzulaufen?
Ja, genau. Hat er das ... Ja.
Das ist so ein schwieriges Thema.
Vielleicht ist das falsch von uns.
Ich weiss es nicht.
Mhm.
- Aus unserer Sicht ...
... war das
einfach nicht in Ordnung.
Aber sie haben immer noch Kontakt.
In einem guten Rahmen.
Es ist eine Freundschaft
und das ist auch gut so.
Nach zwei Monaten
treffe ich sie wieder.
Inzwischen auf der Welt:
der kleine Maël.
Virginie erzählt mir,
die Zeit seit der Geburt
sei schwierig gewesen.
Sie kämpfte mit dem Babyblues,
Samuel wohnte phasenweise
ausschliesslich bei den Eltern.
Und sie hat ihre Stelle gekündigt.
Die Beziehung zwischen ihr und Faik
bleibe immer noch auf der Strecke.
Eine weitere Herausforderung:
Je älter Marvin wird ...
Das haben wir ja befürchtet.
Je älter Marvin wird, desto mehr
werden sie zu Konkurrenten.
Und nicht mehr ...
Es gab schon ein paar Situationen,
in denen Samuel
sich von Marvin angegriffen fühlte.
Gute Nacht, Marvin.
- Was macht ihr dann?
Wir sprechen mit Samuel
und versuchen,
ihm zu erklären,
dass Marvin noch klein ist.
Dass er das noch nicht versteht.
- Der Hund. Komm, versorgen, Marvin.
Versorgen.
- Ja, erklären ist das Einzige.
Aber es ist kein Thema,
dass er zur Entspannung von allen
wieder aus der Familie geht?
Ja ... Doch, natürlich. Die
Diskussion haben wir immer wieder.
Vor Kurzem kam sein Chef und sagte,
er fände es besser,
wenn Samuel betreut wohnen würde.
Aber ...
Ich glaube, es gibt bei jeder
Wohnsituation Vor- und Nachteile.
Gehen wir?
- Was wir immer wieder sagen:
Wir müssen es
immer wieder überprüfen.
Stimmt es noch?
Momentan stimmt es noch.
Beziehungen sind nichts Statisches.
Immer wieder überprüfen Ð
wohl eine gute Lösung.
Hoi, Deborah.
Heute - bei Helden und Heldinnen 21
von Insieme -
ist der grosse Auftritt
von Samuels Tanzgruppe.
Buongiorno. Tutto bene.
Hast du einen neuen Haarschnitt?
Ja.
Man sieht es.
* Heitere Popmusik *
* Das Publikum klatscht mit. *
* Jubel und Applaus *
Wir sind Zwillinge.
Gut gegangen?
- Ja.
Samuel und Virginie sind glücklich.
Nicht nur wegen des Auftritts.
Es ist megacool.
Wir haben in der Zwischenzeit
ein mega Geschenk erhalten.
Wir haben ein Haus gefunden,
in dem ...
... es genug Platz für alle hat.
Es entspricht
voll unseren Vorstellungen:
Ein Wohnzimmer und eine Küche unten.
Und ein Zimmer mit Badezimmer.
Mit eigenem Eingang für ihn.
Wir haben es ihm gezeigt und er
freute sich und meinte: "Super."
Jetzt klären wir halt alles ab.
Wir haben ja noch nie ...
... so eine grosse Investition
getätigt.
Faik hilft mir extrem.
Allein würde ich das nicht machen.
Also, allein
hätte ich auch nicht zwei Kinder.
Ich finde nicht,
dass ich viel helfe.
Doch, mega. Ich bin immer noch
die strenge Schwester.
Die ihn zurechtweisen möchte
oder ...
Das kommt automatisch.
Dann weist er mich zurecht und sagt:
"Jetzt nicht. Lass ihn machen!"
Das hilft mir mega.
Damit ich ihn
einfach auch machen lassen kann.
Die Vorzeichen stehen gut,
den gemeinsamen Weg
glücklich fortzusetzen.
Mit einer gesunden Mischung
aus Nähe und Distanz,
um sich frei zu entwickeln -
jede und jeder auf seine Weise.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022